[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
hey Billy where is it Dominic not got my
headphones on because put them on you
don't know what I'm saying but listen to
this Ryan says you tell me if you can
hear it
can you hear that I'll do it again
now for the listeners out there not the
people watching the show I wonder what
they would guess you closure you know
what it is but close your eyes and say
your best guess of what you think this
is but not be the actual real thing
[Music]
I'll tell you mine yeah an old man
running up a hill in a park trying to
chase after his old dog let me hear it
again
oh yeah
what would you say I would say it was
like uh like a Great Dane has got has
got the scent of a squirrel and a behind
the bush
but he's chasing after he's just now
he's going
how's your dog's nose
what do you mean so you got a good sense
of smell
my dog's got no nose how does he smell
awful hey hey no he does I told you he
found a uh old person yeah no person
it's a horrific story and he found a rat
last night was it in your kitchen my
heart was running through the back
garden and my wife said was that a rat
and I had to see no it was a squirrel
but it was a rat oh no sir Bush will
know now
she doesn't listen to this oh no why
would she
it's lovely to
let just been going on this week well
this
fool Ram Jam full ah get up first thing
in the morning and before I notice last
thing at night we have that conversation
quite a lot I check in with you very
often you never check him with me but
that's fine I always go hey Billy how
was your day and you go that's
absolutely slammed I don't know what
went on and suddenly it's six o'clock
exactly we've got time for a Little
League of Legends you said no I've not
got time I've got the brain space I'm
maybe putting something in the oven
was it halibut no a friend came around
with um Frankenstein now friend came
around with uh would you call that a
pasta with a cheese
yeah and it pelled it up so high
then when I put it in the oven I said
put it in the oven for 30 minutes at
four two five so I did next thing the
whole house was full of smoke because it
dripped off the sage storm onto the
bottom of the oven oh no
I never put a tree underneath I should
put a tree underneath it you see I know
the place was full of smoke
Backdraft I was scared to open the door
yeah yeah you've got to feel the handle
yeah yeah did your dog did Bobby come
over nothing
just sleeping God lovely smell the
cheese in there you smell a bun and
cheese love this smell bun and cheese
and then it sounded like this
oh very strange yeah yeah
in trouble yeah exactly well what time
you've had kitchen mishaps by Billy Boyd
and have you done it this week
doing a lot of doctor stuff are you not
I'm having a colonoscopy now listen
everyone out there if you're 45 or older
there's no shame in it go get a
colonoscopy Ryan Reynolds one of the
great modern day movie stars and may I
say a Dreamboat him and his friend Rob
is it Michael Haney mcelhaney I think
they both had a colonoscopy on camera to
try and rid us all of the shame of a
colonoscopy shouldn't be ashamed it's
more of the hassle isn't it yeah so when
you're getting used
I'm getting mined on this Wednesday no
sorry sorry Thursday and you're okay
yeah because Wednesday I'm doing a whole
liquid diet Thursday morning colonoscopy
yeah Monday
so when's your liquid diet start well
mine is more intention just I was told
not to have any uh fiber Friday right
Saturday
kind of just liquid simple food simple
Foods
Sunday only liquids no color no color in
them
and end Monday and we go so what will
that be for you on Sunday would that be
apple juice grape juice what else are
you thinking that's colorless that you
can get down tea apparently you're also
allowed like um
or is this the day before yeah uh like
uh would you call it like bone broth and
all that all right we allowed that
didn't stipulate to me whether it could
have bone broth or not probably just
have a deal of like nothing water really
yeah clear soups juices
well I look forward to hearing all about
your colon well you'll be first yeah
well I look forward to telling you
peeling The Onion
hey we've had a riddle sent in right go
on I love riddles you know hopefully uh
Eddie I'm producer knows the instances
because we don't
Stuart oh no this is from Calvin Drake
ready Calvin Drake
I have long been buried hey there dead
body it's not finished right carry on
let's start again actually okay I have
long been buried yet still many wish to
Sunder my head and bite my flesh sent on
my
head Thunder
I Do no harm until my skin is pierced
aha
for then they who Pierce me will soon
pay with their tears an onion I think it
is
incredible what else is going on uh let
me think Tom any League of Legends this
week no are you at A League of Legends
update I'll give you one
[Applause]
I've decided to try new uh Champions
because you tell me that I don't play
enough
did I yeah Champions you say all you do
is hey my dinger well there was a point
where I did say that but now you've gone
back to playing Kaiser at quite a good
level yeah so I know I want to try other
things so I tried mod the Kaiser oh yeah
you've been good at work really I think
it's important for you to have two in
each lane so two options in top two
jungle two mid two ADC to support
because if you're playing high meding
and they ban him and you're like well
that's all I can play in mid then you
have to dodge and I don't want to dodge
I've never dodged I dodged the other the
other day because I tried to play
Ash support
someone picked it in the enemy team I
went for locks in mid one of my team
pick blocks I got the jungle so I was
like okay I'll play kha'zix and they
banned kha'zix I was like well I can't
play it's a nightmare Tom you've done
well you can't you can't do any more
than that yeah
so are you ready to Be Your Own Boss yet
start run and grow your own successful
business with Shopify the all-in-one
Commerce platform what's your story's
live Shopify makes getting paid simple
by instantly accepting every type of
payment Shopify grows with your business
anywhere thanks to their endless list of
Integrations and third-party apps
literally everything you can think of
from on-demand printing to accounting to
chart Bots everything you need to
customize your business to your needs is
already in your hands do you want
marketing Made Simple Shopify removes
the guesswork thanks to the built-in
tools that help you create execute and
analyze your online marketing campaigns
running a successful business means
getting the insights you need to grow
wherever you are with Shopify a single
dashboard you'll manage orders shipping
and payments from anywhere now having
your own business can be overwhelming at
the best really there's so much to do
and you feel like it's all on you the
great thing about if I is it takes some
of that workload out of your hands and
makes it really really simple so when
you're ready to launch your thing into
the spotlight do it with Shopify the
Commerce platform backing millions of
businesses down the street and around
the globe go on try Shopify for free and
start selling anywhere this is
possibility powered by Shopify sign up
for a free trial at shopify.com onion or
lowercase go to shopify.com onion to
start selling online today
shopify.com slash onion
your business can't keep waiting for
your dream hire to sweep you off your
feet how do you find them right now you
need indeed indeed as the hiring
platformer you can attract interview and
hire all in one place don't spend hours
on multiple job sites looking for
candidates with the right skills when
you can do it all with indeed find Top
Talent fast with indeed Suite of
powerful hiring tools like indeed
instant match assessments and virtual
interviews hate waiting indeed U.S data
shows over 80 percent of indeed
employers find quality candidates whose
resumes on indeed matches their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job fantastic yeah I mean if your
responsibility at a business is to be
hiring people you and you're on a
computer you can sometimes have 10
windows open up too much of people and
do they do this and do that indeed
brings it all together they make it as
simple as possible it's absolutely
fantastic the right candidate is doing
everything they can to find you and if
you use indeed you can be sure you're
doing everything you can to find them
too finding great talent doesn't have to
be a second job you can reclaim your
time and find the Talent fast with
indeed indeed knows when you're growing
your own business you have to make every
dollar count that's why when you sponsor
a job you only pay for Quality
applications from resumes in our
database matching your job description
visit indeed.com onion to start hiring
now just go to indeed.com onion
indeed.com onion terms and conditions
apply cost per application pricing not
available for everyone need to hire you
need indeed
hey bills what is it Tom Jeff is here
the wonderful Jeff Pros how's it going
man it's good to see you we've never
done anything like this no we haven't in
all the years we've known we've spent a
little bit of time with each other like
off camera and stuff and you've been
very gracious to invite me to some uh
Survivor events that go on in L.A which
I thought I have not come to yet I'm
honestly a little intimidated but
because I'm going to meet some Survivor
people there anyway oh hey oh hey Boston
Rob I met Boston Rob at your house got
very freaked out we should talk about
the fact that I'm a huge you know that
huge Survivor fan huge I love it I know
I'm embarrassed to say that we've never
met Jeff and also I I Survivor sort of
passed me by somehow but not no Jeff
it can pass you by it's okay it's not
for everybody no you've been in my
you've been in my living room these last
few weeks and me and my wife are loving
it really yeah absolutely I wouldn't lie
to you I absolutely love it essentially
the week Jeff and we were texting about
you coming on that you find yourself at
this point in in a pretty unique
situation because you've got me a
Survivor Uber fan and Billy a novice to
the show right and he's very cool you
can be right in the middle of this
conversation it's all you know covid uh
Netflix licensed a couple of Seasons
during covet and a lot of people that
had never seen Survivor saw it right and
so I meet people now who are new and
it's really fun to hear their take on it
not having been on a 22-year journey
yeah they're on a 22-week journey right
and they see the show very differently
because they binge it so they see all
the transitions you know in two weeks
and it's interesting how that changes
their perception of the show I'm
assuming that you don't personally go
back and watch previous seasons of
Survivor or do you not really I've tried
to go back and watch season one but it
is so painful for me personally yeah to
just look at my yourself and listen to
myself that I can't do it even for fun
I'm like it's just so painful it's this
is gonna really do some damage to my
self-esteem I mean the evolution of the
show is extraordinary and something that
I definitely want to talk to you about
but I I agree I mean I I've seen every
single season of Survivor it looks like
a completely different [ __ ] it doesn't
even look like the same show and in
season one you guys are still figuring
out a lot of stuff right in season one
we had 80 crew members we now including
locals like in Fiji we are now close to
a thousand oh wow we had 80 people doing
everything Mark was carrying tripod
sticks I was everybody you were
traipsing through the mud for an hour to
get somewhere because we only had five
boats and we lost three of them in a
storm I mean it was it was real and it
was also
I remember being in a little like a I
don't know it was some sort of cubicle
we'd put in the middle of Borneo
and I had a white board because Regis
Philbin was doing Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire and he had this line is that
your final answer and I kept saying we
got to have a line and everybody's
looking at me like ah dude you're
overthinking this but my point being we
didn't even have the tribe has spoken
right yet right we were still it was
just sort of coming all at once and Mark
was such a great leader because
he was Fearless if you had an idea he'd
say I don't know don't
it's a pretty good idea let's try that
you know and then you just do it and see
if it works yeah well let's let's talk
about the format of the show because
this is something that you and I have
talked about a lot and something that I
know gets you really excited Survivor is
quite a regimented formatted show right
and it's something that you really lean
into is it is it the idea that you want
the audience to be reminded that they
are in a game show that this is a game
all the time is that the idea behind the
form not for me it's not that it might
be subconsciously what you're picking up
on but for me it's
I am a big format guy when I see a good
format I respect that somebody built
that format and it's pres and it's
precise and so with Survivor the four
the ques the question I always have
because this show is done in other
countries different producers
is what do you think the format is right
I think the format is
philosophical
it's you take a group of people
strangers typically
and unless you're doing an All-Star
season and you force them to live
together where they must rely on each
other to survive while simultaneously
voting each other out and in the end a
group of the people that you voted out
will now decide who wins who played the
best game what's the best game depends
on the people deciding for me that's it
you the you could add in there are
reward challenges there are immunity
challenges maybe maybe you don't have to
have them right we don't know we may get
to season where we don't do that and
people will go oh my God you've blown it
again but so I just pay attention and
remind myself every season I go back
through what is this show about every
episode we just finished episode seven
one of the things that's really strong
in episode seven is this contrast of
rely on each other but compete against
each other right and it's subtle you
shouldn't notice it yeah but it's always
there yeah yeah yeah and like people now
playing Survivor a full fully aware of
the game that they're walking into and
you would think that they would be a
little bit more Wily about the way that
they should behave but everyone breaks
down everyone double crosses everyone
makes a mistake everyone lie I mean you
have to lie in this show yeah I think
about I mean it's my favorite show on TV
and I think about the people in my life
playing Survivor and like Billy for
instance with respect Billy is too nice
to play the game yeah that is a bit
brilliant you wouldn't that would be
amazing really you don't backstab you
don't say to someone Absolutely I'll do
it and then walk around the corner and
go I'm gonna mess up that person's game
you would you wouldn't have the the you
need to be a bit of a like getting into
the needle of the game I just don't
think you'd have that I don't think you
would bills physically I think you'd be
fine the social game some aspect of it I
think it'd be great so this is a game
you have to be a bit of a bad person but
this is what's great is Billy has never
played nor have you because I always
tell Dom I think he'd be really good
because he has great social skills he's
got great emotional intelligence he can
read a room and go I don't know I'm not
trusting the eyes on that one but what
dominic wouldn't know is what you are
really thinking yeah and in an interview
you could go it's going to be so hard
for my friend when I write his name name
down tonight yeah but he's going home
long before I do and that could happen
and then Dom is like well that's
[ __ ] I don't know I'm a better
player I don't know are you yeah yeah
that yeah yeah I know exactly what you
mean and Legacy I'm new to it so I'm I'm
watching so I'm watching the new one
okay so I'm watching people who are all
fans of this show playing the show but
then like you said in in one of the
meetings in a an early episode there
that uh why does everyone tell everyone
the truth right and you're trying to
figure out even at this level and
they're saying oh sorry and they're
seeing because
oh oh the only thing you have to bargain
with is your honesty your trust your
trust if they trust you yeah then that
is such a huge thing so if you find
something and you go in and you tell
everyone that you've found it then
everyone goes oh I'll trust him right so
then you've you've you've got a little
score there I mean maybe you know it's
always changing it's always changing and
it depends on the group yeah the group
dynamic we're always surprised this
season Survivor 43 is very different
from Survivor 44 but it's the same game
yeah yeah it's but it's it's the
different players yeah yeah and also
such a great show it changes each week
because that Dynamic shift because that
person's gone and maybe they had a
connection with that person or maybe
they learned to trust that person what I
found over over there as a general rule
with Survivor over the years it's
obviously not an exact science is if you
can convince people that they can trust
you even though you're going to stab
them in the back those people seem to go
a long way it's not the out and out
trustworthy people like whatever
Rupert's not gonna lie you think oh well
that's someone it is Boston Rob where
you're like I really want to trust you
but I kind of know that you're going to
screw me at some point those people seem
to go that's a great obligation you're a
lot like that I think yeah I can't
believe that
no that's true I wanted to ask you like
we're talking about the format and one
of the things that I noticed changed
which was which is something just to
talk about in terms of where we're at
right now with Society you drop the word
guys yeah from comment come on in guys
so every time a uh like
um a challenge starts Jeff there'll be
no one on the beach and Jeff will say
come on in guys yeah we'll come in now
at one point was it last season it was
41. 41. when we came back after covet
after black lives matters me too all of
this stuff was happening in our culture
all this great movement yeah and yeah
you so you brought them all together
and you had said as you guys know or as
as you all know exactly I usually say
guys let's open up the Forum here to see
what you thought about it and what I
love about that because I've said this
to you recently as well is those little
moments where I see you at the end of
the show say you know you say okay you
guys get together and then we'll we'll
start the challenge you have like a
couple of seconds now if you're going
all right yeah and I love seeing the
little behind the scenes bit that was a
great thing that featured in the show
where you say to the contestants you're
gonna decide it's not gonna be an
audience thing it's not going to be be a
producerial thing you guys are going to
decide and they decide to drop the guys
so from now on you just say come on in
right yeah and you've said guys like
five times yeah I mean that's the
problem with it I'm glad you asked me
because I have not had a chance to
comment on this since it happened
I learned from from someone who told me
we were talking about it and I said you
know people have criticized like we're
too woke like you should never do that
and I said well I don't know I have two
kids I have a boy and a girl and had I
said 20 years ago come on in ladies
everybody would have thought that was
weird I want my daughter to know if you
think that's a weird word gender-wise I
got you I I don't want to be that guy
that person that guy
but what somebody pointed out to me was
the mistake I made was I made it I made
it a moment and in that way I made it
about me
and and he said you know if you just
didn't want to do it stop doing it and I
really appreciated that because I was
uncomfortable with making it such a big
deal but
one of the things about Survivor it's
like if you're a Howard Stern fan you
listen to 30 years of stern the show's
from 25 years ago he might not do today
yeah he'd be canceled right right so I
have made lots of of decisions
creatively or my grammar or whatever
that I wish I could change but I try to
treat myself the same way as we treat
players that's what I said so that's in
the show
we were in my defense
it was so top of mind everything our
language how we were treating each other
I mean you know unconscious bias which
I'm still trying to learn about my own
so I was really concerned that I don't
want this is my one opportunity we've
been off the air covet happened so I
made that decision if I could do it
again I would do what this guy suggested
and he's a big movie producer a very
smart guy and I would have just done it
and said this was for me yeah I don't
have to explain it I understand I I
personally love the moment it's one of
the one of the things that I love about
you the most when I've spent time at
your house having a party you and your
wife would be like hey we're gonna have
this conversation we're going to talk
about this thing that might be a little
bit we're going to dive in we're here no
one's moving I love friends like that I
love people that just kind of say let's
talk about something that's going to be
a little tricky let's talk about
something a little bit delicate
hey Billy what do you remember the days
before streaming services I do you'd
come home from maybe school it was only
a few hours until that TV show that
everyone at school was watching I know
and maybe your friends would come over
yeah yeah your friends would come over
you'd have some popcorn maybe a little
can of Coke or something well in 1999
you want to guess what that show was it
was Buffy the Vampire Slayer you've
nailed it in the new podcast from
wondery The re-watcher Buffy the Vampire
Slayer we're taking it back to 1999. get
out your knee-high boots and paste that
poster of angel on the wall it's time to
enter The Buffy verse join morbid cool
hosts Ash and Elena as they slay their
way through Buffy's Drama Action and
romance Episode by episode fantastic
into the buffyverse with Elena and Ash
listen to The re-watcher Buffy the
Vampire Slayer on Amazon music Apple
podcast or listen early and AD free by
subscribing to wondery Plus in apple
podcast or the laundry app
Reserve Bar is your online source for
premium and luxury Spirits wine and
champagne and now Reserve Bar offers
same day delivery Reserve Bar has a vast
lineup of rare and hard to find bottles
premium Brands celebrities spirits and
limited releases that you just won't
find in your local store I know no one
does Spirit gifting better than Reserve
Bar you're looking for an elevated gift
reservebar.com has you covered and you
can have that gift delivered right to
their door even better turn that
spirit's gift into a cherished Memento
with custom engraving perfect for
birthdays weddings anniversaries
Father's Day you name it yeah getting
into home bartending Reserve Bar has
everything you need Spirits for the
shells sure but they also have every
barware tool and glass you need
Reserve Bar is a great feature called
cocktail lounge this is a treasure Trove
of cocktail rest to be bartending tits
interviews with Master distillers
celebrities and more and the hot
trending Spirits Billy is ready to drink
cocktails have you tried them yes
they're delicious you're drinking one
right now they taste better than ever
and Reserve Bar has a huge collection of
them these canned cocktails are great
for parties when you don't have time to
tend the bar or for tailgating season
which supposedly is uh following swing
right now Reserve Bar also has barware
glassware cocktail recipes and more need
something for a party tonight reserved
by now offers same day delivery straight
to your door did you forget that special
birthday gift Reserve Bar to the rescue
with same-day delivery visit
reservebar.com today and use promo code
onion to save ten dollars off your
purchase of 75 or more on Spirits wine
or pre-made cocktails but only when you
use our special offer at reservebar.com
with the code onion that's
reservebar.com and code onion this offer
expires the December 31st 2022
let me ask about the bath since I'm
wearing a buff right now one of my
favorite things what are the rules with
the Buffs is the rule that you have to
wear it as some in some part of your
body all times yes anywhere yeah
anywhere and it's really just it goes
back to the very beginning when we were
trying to figure out how do you let the
audience identify that that's one tribe
and that's the other tribe and the
easiest way is just color we're not
going to give them uniforms like at one
point I remember somebody saying well
they could all wear shirts we're like no
no they're going to wear their clothes
so we try to get we know who's going to
be on which tribe we'll say hey Dom
you're going to be on a tribe could you
look in the blues or the purples yeah
and the same with the Buffs and it's
just so that when you're in a shot you
you're reminded oh that's right Dom is
not on Billy's tribe Billy has a blue
buff right it's it's again it goes back
you're picking up from the little tiny
things of the fabric of the tapestry
yeah if you lost the Buffs would the
show change
no but it wouldn't be the same yeah yeah
you know I think still the most popular
item at cbs.com is a Survivor buff I
love the bus was a buff these things why
is it called a buff well it's just the
name of the thing right but it's a buff
yeah so very often you will see yeah
ladies wearing them kind of you know
like a little bikini kind of uh top
thing guys will wear them around their
wrist maybe you use them as a headband
but so if let's say the camera crew are
shooting a scene and they noticed that
someone is not wearing the buff will
they stop down for a second and say hey
could you just put your buff on will
they have those moments with them yeah I
mean it wouldn't be a camera operator
they don't really talk to the players
but but one of our producers or a second
producer it's very I can't imagine that
really happens yeah it's very rare and
our players
we treat our players you know with love
and respect at least you know that's
what I we feel so it's never contentious
or adversarial it'd be hey Dom I know
you went into the uh ocean to to wash
off each could you put your buff back on
right it'd be very casual that's not a
big deal right honestly we don't really
have any issues with the players uh the
one thing we asked them
you have to be honest with us in your
interview you cannot lie because that's
how we tell the story right we don't
have people lying occasionally like once
every five years there'll be a player in
their first interview saying so you
promise you're not going to use this
information and then go tell Billy what
Dom said no our entire Foundation is
built on this trust so you know I think
one of the biggest misunderstandings
with me and players is because I'm sort
of adversarial at times
that I don't like players or I don't
like specific players or I'm hard on a
player I have respect for everyone with
a couple of exceptions over 600 people
Johnny family no even fairplay's not on
that list okay no
but I just have tremendous respect
because they're out there doing it yeah
yeah it's a tough game well one of my
favorite things about you is as the host
is that you have to consistently wear
different hats so there are times where
you will kind of metaphorically put your
arm around a contestant to get that
reaction there are times in a challenge
where you'll be pointing at someone
saying let's go you're going to lose
this challenge if you don't pick up your
game
my favorite version of of the Jeff the
host character is a tribal because you
and you had told me uh years ago that
the way that a contestant is able to
navigate their own way through tribal is
by answering a question honestly and if
you see that someone is dodging or maybe
not telling you the exact truth you'll
zero in on them and keep going after
them until they're honest well I I
remember this conversation it it it's
not honest
it's it has to move it has to have like
I always tell the players actually the
contrary I say you don't ever have to
tell me the truth oh because they could
be playing the game yes but you have to
give me an answer because what people
would love to say is I don't know right
like Dom what do you think's happening
right now we've got seven people which
is a you know kind of an unusual number
it's an odd number obvious I don't know
Jeff then I say okay that's not gonna
work yeah yeah yeah but we're gonna talk
but we don't also have that issue we put
people on the show but years ago when we
were still kind of figuring out casting
there would be people who would say it's
just strategy and then I think okay we
can do this the easy way or the hard way
but now you know you're really also
making me realize my own growth I'm not
that same I'm not interested in that
same story as a human yeah you know like
it used to be
red tribe versus blue tribe yeah and we
might call it something you know brains
Brown and Beauty whatever it is for me
now even though there are still tribes I
see this as an individual Pursuit
because that's where I'm at in my life
so you are on a tribe with other people
and you do want to beat Billy's tribe
because he's on the other tribe but all
I'm seeing is 18 people 17 people 16
people 15 people so my spiritual place
in the world is why are you here right
right what do you want from this yeah
yeah is it really just a million dollars
probably not no because you'll find that
almost every single player across the
board when they leave will say I had an
amazing time this was an incredible
experience best thing I've ever done in
my life they've not won their Millions
right it's only one person that does it
right it's it's getting through those
thunderstorms at night it's lighting the
fire for the first time it's winning a
challenge you know I remember seeing um
Siri really struggle with the physical
challenges and then there's a point
where she actually is like okay you know
what I'm gonna do something here and
that's an amazing moment in her life to
realize how capable one of the best
moments maybe the singular best moment
that represents Survivor is Siri
in I think it was Game Changers
and Siri is this woman Billy who was the
first person that ever said I was
watching Survivor and I decided to get
up off the couch and apply and she
represented the every person because she
didn't look like she belonged in a
jungle she was a nurse a caregiver she
didn't live out in the you know weeds
but she came and she played and people
fell in love with her she's still one of
the most beloved people of all time
humans and everything but there was a
challenge where they had to cross a
balance beam in the middle of the ocean
she couldn't do it yeah and there's a
point in the story of that where the
challenge is clearly going to be won by
the other tribe but that's not what's
interesting what's interesting is you
yeah Siri that person you're sitting
here right now are you gonna try to pull
yourself up on this platform and try to
cross that beam or are you just gonna
say I'm done yeah and all the attention
turned to Siri yeah and I remember
saying we're not going anywhere we got
nothing to do yeah but help you and she
got across and it was this incredible
moment and she ends up getting voted out
you know again because that's how
Survivor works yeah yeah that's the
stuff that gives you the Goosebumps on
your arms absolutely you can see that
already and going back to the tribal
thing something I was thinking watching
it the other day and this might be very
obvious but you being there
it seemed like everyone had made their
mind up you know okay we're at the we're
a Duo and we're a Jew and we're gonna
you know it's all worked out before they
got there and then when you started
talking to them I felt like I think a
couple of these guys are changing their
mind sitting there and the tribal thing
whereas I would have thought well once
you've made me and Dom are going to vote
him out then that's it right but it felt
like just sitting having that chat I
could see people like
change does that happen well you're very
perceptive perceptive because in the
early years it didn't change very often
yeah people were petrified and they
would just let's stick we've done it
yeah we're good it's not that way
anymore yeah and if you say something at
tribal that does not jive with what Dom
thought you told him earlier he now
starts to think wait a minute is Billy
lying to me I may go to plan B so they
have all kinds of signals you know tug
on an ear they say a weird word I don't
ever know what they are but I know
enough to know that everybody's playing
yeah and the vote does change and they
you know there's this phrase live tribal
which drives some people crazy but it
really just speaks to the idea that if
you think it's over just because you're
sitting at tribal it's probably you yeah
yeah sure yeah the live travel thing is
much more of a modern society yes
Survivor thing and I love how perceptive
the camera crew are in the live tribal
because if you if one of the contestants
kind of does a little oh they're on it
oh man they've got that lovely close-up
and then they'll cut to you and you'll
be like okay I'm just gonna sit back and
watch Dom I love you you said that
because
sometimes a Survivor scene like a
reality scene where there's three people
talking and they're conspiring about
what they're gonna do
it will be when you see it it's so good
that you just think well that's what
television shows look like because
there's a like you you all as actors and
producers know there'll be a three shot
there's an over the shoulder there's a
tilt up from the hand to the face boom
over to here but often it's one camera
operator in the field who got stuck
alone three people he doesn't have
Invader she doesn't have anybody so he's
got to get the three shot the sh the two
the relationship shots get wider get us
behind and you look at one disc and
you're like one person shot all of this
yeah man and as you said had the
instinct to know Billy's about to say
something I'm gonna pull over to Billy
boom I got it it blows me away it's I
often say when I'm watching early Cuts
I'll be like it God you would think this
was a scripted show where we had all day
to shoot this scene but it happened in
four minutes yeah yeah yeah it can't be
scripted because of all of the different
human dynamics going on I think probably
must have been 10 years ago Billy that I
was trying to get you to watch Survivor
do you remember yeah Billy was well more
than actually was still in Scotland you
went back to Scotland at that point so
it's probably closer to 14 15 years ago
been a Survivor fan since it came on I
said to Billy at one point he's with his
wife I said what are you doing he said
well we're going to go home jet lagged
and stuff I said take
heroes and villains you're so good yeah
I was gonna take this it is my all-time
favorite season of Survivor take these
DVDs watch it then you've got season
after season after season that you can
keep watching we lost that TV I lost a
DVD
my favorite season of Survivor he lost
yeah he wasn't pleased no I not only did
he not watch it but you lost it but the
the pitch the pitch that I'd always said
to Billy in the pitch that I always said
to my friends who you know Jeff I'm sure
you have it nowadays after 42 43 season
survive at 43. you must have people kind
of saying wow okay you know that show's
still on and how do you make it fresh
and how do you make it current I say to
them to my friends I'm like it is
constantly evolving the show but it
doesn't necessarily need to although I
completely appreciate why it happens
because the bones the foundation of that
show is so strong you know the the
physical challenges mixed with the
mental endurance mixed with the the life
at Camp then all the contestants eating
each other and backstabbing each other
and then that final thing of all of
these people that you've betrayed are
now going to decide who wins like I'm
gonna come and watch the finale with you
guys and you're gonna you're not invited
yeah you're going to be so confused
because you're going to be like wait all
these people probably kind of dislike
the person that they're giving a million
dollars to but that's what they have to
do
okay but I'm gonna this is the the
biggest question around Survivor I hear
all the time ah you don't really need
all the twists and you know well we'll
never know because we we're that's what
we're doing but here's my argument from
a game design standpoint what I'm doing
when we're not shooting is I'm just
designing the game and uncertainty
is what compels somebody at tribal to do
what we just talked about which is wait
why did Billy why did Billy say that
that sounded weird does he have blank an
advantage a relationship uncertainty so
I felt like watching the early Seasons
when they were playing out thinking this
idea that if there are 12 people and
seven are together they can dominate the
five is disastrous yeah yeah you have to
make it very difficult so you start
interjecting things into the show
injecting things that makes somebody on
the seven realize I think I'm seven yeah
I could be six if I went to the five
yeah so that's you know I've been trying
to scream from the top of rooftops at
today's players who get frustrated with
all the twists
it's almost like I'm a parent saying I'm
gonna that which you resist will persist
I'm going to push more and more until
you realize this is not what the game's
about the game is about adaptation [ __ ]
happens you wake up in the morning you
got a weird feeling you go to the doctor
you're sick [ __ ] happens Survivor you
wake up you find a beware Advantage do
you open it or not yeah beware also not
the future players beware advantages are
not going away and they're not going to
get less scary yeah so I feel like you
do need that and the mistake players
make
is they get caught up in it you know
like the change history twist we did
yeah there was a guy Danny on that
season who I think could have won the
game I mean he's just a you know he's a
really smart super clever very likable
and physical he could win but he got so
mad for 48 hours that he took his eyes
off the prize and I still think back and
think did that
just did that little course correction
hurt you versus dude it is you can be
mad at me later yeah yeah but don't mess
up your game because you're mad yeah it
is just minor things that can change the
course of a contestant in in Survivor
well let me ask you about the the beware
Advantage the legalities of that okay
let's say billionaire playing Survivor
and and we're walking along the beach
and I see the beware Advantage but I
personally think I'm not gonna go
anywhere near that I know what that
means if I cajole Billy into opening it
let's play a game oh yeah all right I
keep waiting for that to happen because
of you know
so far the beware Advantage hasn't
really burned anybody but you do have to
do things like it's going to make you
now go get beads to be in you know to
form your necklace which at home can
sometimes seem easy it's not no no that
is dicey because if you you can't give
it away and you can't be too aggressive
so yeah I think one day somebody's gonna
probably do what you just said yeah and
get lucky and it burns the person who
picked it up and it will say this is why
it says beware yeah yeah I like is it
Colby is it the is that one of the
contestants this year Cody Cody Cody so
Cody uh picked up the beware advantage
and I like the fact that that someone at
that point maybe it was Cody explained
that if with these guys all being super
fans giving away beads yeah is something
that you would want to take home at the
end of the game and so so when they're
done when they get when they get kicked
out of the game do you guys from a
courtesy point of view say you can keep
your bag you keep your buff you what
what kind of that you can your personal
bag and your buff we used to let you
like if you say had an idol and you
didn't use it you could keep it as a
souvenir we don't do that anymore either
because now we we think of everything as
future like you know this knowledge is
power Advantage idea is is fascinating
because because it's such a simple idea
if you know
the information with this little piece
of paper you can change the game the
question is who knows you have this
little piece of paper back to what Billy
said because I told my best friend that
I have the knowledge of power I didn't
realize he isn't my best friend he told
his best friend and she told everybody
something like that knowledge is power
piece of paper one season is going to go
from one player to the next to the next
the same piece of paper and it'll be
cursed and then in a future season we'll
bring it back and say this same piece of
paper is burned for people so we try to
keep all of that and keep it in a locker
and you know keep it dry in case we want
to use it again I would imagine that the
the contracts for the contestants are
relatively thick right relatively thick
yeah yes if you make it from the start
to the end how long are you there 26
days it used to be 39. wow Billy it's
another bone of contention for some
people because
some people feel like well if it's not
39 days it's not Survivor I don't feel
that way but the old school people that
have won you mean yes yeah they're like
well you didn't play the way I played
and I'm not taking anything away from
them 39 days is a long time there's no
reason to argue about this I'm just
merely saying we spent a lot of time
redesigning the game like the fact that
there is no food at all for those first
16 17 18 days people are saying that by
day three by day three they're just like
yeah I am hungry but I want to be clear
I'm not it's apples and bananas yeah
they're different games but this is the
game and we like it and we think there's
a lot of Runway to play so at what point
and I'm sure you've had it during the
run of the show at what point does a
medic step in in terms of a food there's
always fresh water right right so
there's a well or somewhere where you
can get fresh water well and that water
has been cleaned by something
professionally right so there's always
water in terms of food when does the
medic step in and say you know what guys
this person needs a bowl of rice so this
person needs something well we do you
know we discussed it beforehand when we
knew how many days we were planning to
go in this new era and our medical team
was fine with it you know they said
they'll be fine they'll be hungry but
they'll be fine and they can catch fish
and sometimes they do and they get a
little bit of meat but if we if
something happened and our design was
off and they said you know they're in
trouble then we would introduce a reward
into the game you'd still have to earn
it or we would say hey if you're really
hungry give me your tarp we would do
something we would never just give it it
would still be in the game but our job
is to make sure that we're we've laid it
out in a way that that doesn't happen
yeah and you have done that in in the
show quite a few times where you'll say
I'll give you this for your time yeah
well usually it's when in past seasons
in the 39 day version they would have a
bunch of rice and they would eat all of
it and in that case our medical team
would say hey they're just eating too
much right and so that's why there was
an invoice it would be yeah if you want
another bag of rice I want everything
right right because we designed this to
work in that other tribe they still have
rice right so you can't say it's not
enough yeah it's not as much as you want
yeah it never is but it's enough I have
to say over the over the is it is 42
Seasons now this is our 43rd so over the
over the 43 Seasons I'm still astounded
that less people have chopped their
thumb off trying to open up because most
thing that the other day most people
you're right playing the game have never
opened a coconut before you're right and
almost all of them give it a go during
that time and you will see people just
hacking at it but that's I'm here and I
just think someone's gonna lose a thumb
so it's not happening yet has it no but
you're I think the same thing when we do
challenges where there we have one I
maybe even this season where you have to
take a machete and chop a rope to get
something to drop yeah we put the
dullest machete we can because of me
because I'm always saying to the art
Department please tell me that that if
they because they're they're frenetic
yeah yeah
yes I've since I became a dad I see
challenges so differently now I'm the
worst for the art department and
challenge Department because I am now
the guy going oh it might be too big
that might be too high of a jump do you
really think couldn't it be just as cool
and we shoot a little lower and they're
like who are you yeah yeah don't be so
responsible uh yeah the water challenges
are probably my favorite because it's
usually not strictly a water challenge
there'll be a water challenge that might
involve the little bit of land anything
that has some element of water in I love
let me ask you this yeah
what do you personally think would you
would be the best in in any of the
physical challenges if they were if you
had to run one of those to save your
life where's your strong suit
um that's so good I cannot believe I've
actually not contemplated what elements
I would be good at yeah that's funny
they always say would you be good at
challenges but you'd be good at
challenges you're a very physically fit
guy and you know your way around them by
now but what you where are you sure I
think I'd be good at like like I've
learned enough over the years about
balance beams that you look ahead and
you just go go you don't look down you
don't take your time you just and if you
fall okay you fall I can get up walls I
could untie ropes I think water I can
swim but I'm not fast yeah and how about
puzzles well I was gonna say and going
underwater
one time just I don't know in the last
10 years we started a season the way
we're going to start it we were on a
boat and you were going to have to get
supplies and then one person from your
tribe had to jump off the boat swim out
and there was one big giant reward so
the fastest swimmer would get it yeah
and we were out testing it and they
weren't sure like is it too deep and I
go let me go because I'm average yeah so
I swim out I'm not kidding maybe 15 feet
maybe from here to the edge of this
studio yeah and then I have to dive down
only like four feet right I couldn't do
it got no breath the ocean is just yeah
and it was so good for me to do it
because it reminded me on TV you're like
just once you see somebody do it and it
looks easy they're a stud they're crazy
good because it's really hard so if it
was that kind of stuff I'd still be
underwater struggling yeah yeah and
you'd be back on top of me going bro it
was good sucking it up no I mean you you
must have those challenges a lot when
people say when they're watching
Survivor man you could you know you
could make that a little easier Aussie
seems to be just flying through it and
you're like Aussie is a one in a million
exactly yes yeah in fact our art
Department to try to to your point
this year
usually you go underwater and you'd have
to unclip something and it's hard
because you can't see it's the ocean
it's not a swimming pool you know
and you're not going to wear a mask
probably sometimes
our art Department's so cool a guy made
a mechanism where instead of having it
on clip you just squeeze the handle and
it releases and what it did was because
the test wasn't can you unclip the test
was to see you go underwater and pop
this buoy and in that one little stroke
of Genius from somebody in our art
Department you now have people who can
be a rock star they can dive down get to
the buoy and instead of panicking with a
clip pull the lever boom it pops because
they've done the thing that they're
supposed to do exactly don't feel when
uh yeah technicality yes and so now it's
a rock star moment that you want to do
because it's cool and we got a camera
right there you know it's a great
physical one this year I thought was
brilliant was the big snake oh the snake
because if you've got two really strong
guys it doesn't matter because this what
was this like 400 400 and it was long so
two guys wouldn't be not enough
well as well yeah
[Music]
that's where you're watching like I'm on
the beach going oh I hope they they can
do this yeah we've tested it but you
never know and then slowly but surely
they get the last bit of the tail
everyone you need everyone to begin that
was good okay this goes back to the
format
those first five or six episodes where
you're a tribe you were forced to rely
on each other so if you have somebody
that's really great in the water and
really strong
you need to keep them to get the snake
up yeah but then you have to vote people
out and that person's not in your
alliance so you want to vote them out
but if you vote them out your tribes
weak you might lose and go it's that's
the problem with the game yeah yeah it
all starts to like collapse in on itself
already talking about Anthony they're
like we need to keep him because he's so
strong he can keep us out of the tribal
thing yeah but we're also scared of him
because he's going to win this he's so
strong yeah yeah well at the moment
we're obviously we're not too far into
um Survivor there's a new episode
tonight but at the moment Cody is like
the the front runner Fuller Charisma is
a good looking man he seems to be
playing his game very honestly he was
great in that physical challenge he's
the guy that goes over the other side
and basically uses his body weight just
to try and he's the guy who's off doing
his own thing yeah he's a surfer dude I
bet you see done
[Music]
he's already alive yeah yeah because
he's a Salesman yeah and he's not told
everybody he's a Salesman yeah I love it
you know what else is really interesting
is you never know we never know who the
audience will like we know who we liked
when we were out there yeah Cody was
Charming from the minute we met him yeah
but that doesn't mean the audience you
could have a they could have vibed on
him and went I don't know the surfer
dude but instead everywhere I go people
like Cody yeah he just pops he pops but
it then there's a young guy as well he's
good he's like 19 but he's told him he's
23. oh yeah there's like No One's Gonna
respect someone which is funny that he
goes he said 22 I think
22. yeah yeah but it's enough just to
get that little bit of respect that's
true they seems to be Sly mirror images
of each other those two both kind of
athletic both you know slightly
masculine dominant energies those two a
question from uh my wife from this
season what happened to the girl's chin
yeah she just wasn't scraped up was that
when she was trying to dig the hole
under the I don't remember because uh
yeah it's pretty Brew it's pretty nice I
mean she seems okay with it she's just
rolling with it yeah there's been a lot
of very physical challenges on the show
and then every so often you'll have a
physical challenge where you'll put
humans against humans you know the the
kind of two two netball Nets and you
have to put the ball yeah
obviously in the stuff that we've seen
it can get a little rambunctious yeah
are there moments that don't get filmed
where you've had to step in and say guys
you can't throw punches you can't be
drowning people but there's a reason
we're not really doing them anymore oh
is that just it just kind of it just got
too a bit rough why but no I I gotta say
again to the players you know on that
those challenges in particular I would
say look obviously this would be the
speeches you can't throw a punch if you
do you're out of here don't hold which
has never happened yet no don't hold
somebody underwater that's just not cool
but then the thing that really gets them
is when you remind them if you get to
the end some of these people maybe all
of them maybe on your jury so play the
game the way you want to play it's okay
to play hard yeah but just I've gotten
less comfortable with it yeah and maybe
that's because I'm more woke I don't
know but there's no need we our
challenges are bigger than than ever
this year and next season this season
and next season they're tougher than
ever they are they are tough but they're
achievable you just gotta work together
they're like you'll see a lot more walls
that you have to get up that you can't
get up without somebody right right it's
impossible right so you got to rely
right you gotta build your shoulders
mentality and then you got to vote that
person exactly
um in those kind of intimate moments
that you guys build into the show
someone's found a hidden Idol they need
to have a Talking Heads moment with the
camera crew someone's having an intimate
moment with the camera crew where
they're talking about a loved one that
they're missing or can they get through
this next tribal what's to stop one of
the other fellow contestants just to
walk down the beach at that point and
completely ruin that we protect them so
we're doing interviews so do you say to
the contestants hey guys we're taking 10
minutes over here stay in the camp no we
don't say that we just take some we say
you know if we were taking you for an
interview we'd take you somewhere
private and we have some a second
producer who's watching to make sure
that nobody would try if they were so
inclined to get it within earshot of the
of the interview that doesn't happen it
just it just doesn't people don't do
that we wouldn't tolerate it right we're
really clear that we don't ask for much
right right but but you gotta but that's
not cool the only things we ask like I
said were be honest and you have to
respect our crew right right because if
anybody did say something
you know whatever like I don't know say
something to a camera operator or a
second producer or anybody we would
definitely pull them aside and say that
will not fly yeah everybody out here is
busting their ass but again Dom I know I
sound like a broken record
most people are really good to work with
yeah of course they get tired and
irritable and all that but we understand
that yeah but we don't really have like
I'm telling you this group they're as
likable as they seem and we've just
started yeah so much to get to know
about them how how close are the camps
well not close enough to get they would
they couldn't get to the other no right
I mean I suppose you could if you got in
a boat and started paddling that was
your thing but how what is a normal day
like uh like cameraman and as is there
always someone in the camera always how
many a couple of cameras several Crews
during the day and usually at night
often it's one segment producer who's
getting there it's often their first
real responsibility and it's a big one
because the good news is they'll
probably sleep all night the bad news is
someone might get up and if they were
good news I guess depending on how you
look at it but if they do it's on you
you're the camera operator you're the
producer when something happens you got
to get the coverage and it's a real
you know it's often seen as oh I got
Knights but for us it's this is how much
faith we have in you and your future on
the show is we're putting you we're
giving you nights right okay where
you're alone and Billy they'll the
producer will have to sit out there in
the rain yeah the survivors might have a
shelter it might keep them dry they're
not in the shelter they're out there and
every so often in the middle of the
night I will call at the beach just to
see how they're doing it's 3 A.M probes
for tc1
yeah how you doing
it's it's pretty wet
you loving it
absolutely all right later good night
okay good night you know I'm not
sleeping Jeff right you're going to
sleep I'm not yeah they were expecting
you're gonna bring like chicken wings
yeah right not happening I love that
they they all said basically after one
day they're like you'll never dry here
you're just never try yeah yeah the
humidity in the air yeah and then cold
at night really yeah and then your
Fire's not always burning which that
little thing of that penalty of taking
their Flint if they lose a challenge you
know we we have only so much time in an
episode but you know we could do a
minute on people trying to get their
fire going yeah yeah you know you guys
you two appreciate this we're still a
linear show we're on CBS network even
though you can see it on Paramount plus
and CBS is still limited to 42 minutes
43 seconds yeah if we were on a streamer
one episode could be 51 minutes yeah it
wouldn't matter yeah
what's been
the scariest moment as a producer of the
show what's that moment where you're
either in the field or you get a phone
call that made you go uh this is a big
problem now I think the scariest one
was this season when we had a guy we had
three people go down at once in a
challenge they were digging and roasting
hot day yeah yeah and they were digging
a hole and and the flag was there they
just it was one of those inexplicable
they just kept missing it and one woman
one woman had sort of just little high
little dehydration a little heat she was
okay the other woman was pretty bad and
the guy was really bad and I knew it was
bad when the woman was vomiting and our
doctor said she'll be okay well that's
how bad he was and I I was holding his
head and
and uh there was just a moment there
where I I wasn't sure he everything was
okay and he's he's all good but you
brought in a helicopter for that oh yeah
yeah that was a big evacuation and
that's when you really see how good our
safety and teams are I mean we have you
know this guy Greg Blandy he he's our
safety guy and a lot of the times he's
looking to make sure that you put a
railing on something if it's really high
you know stuff that you could say okay
but when Blandy needs to be on because
something's happening or like somebody
in the water is in trouble he's an
expert swimmer all of a sudden you go
that's why he's here yeah so and then we
have a helicopter pilot Ken Gray that's
the guy that knows how to transport
quickly can do that if he has to fly at
night he will you know all those things
you don't want them to ever have to do
anything and our medical decisions are
made by our doctors we don't have any
say on that yeah so the deal is if they
can stay let them stay if they can't
stay pull them it's up to you and it's
heartbreaking you've seen it when they
pull somebody they don't want to do it
but they never want to do it but they
don't even hesitate because it's not
worth it yeah yeah I don't think I want
to do this Jeff because I'm I'm loving
I'm loving watching this and I'm loving
in that it's a weekly thing that I can't
binge it is the best oh hold on go on
but if a dead want to binge Whaler
watched the new one what what season
should I binge oh man well Heroes versus
Villains is a good one that's a great
one um David Goliath is a good one
Millennials versus Gen X is a good one
Pearl islands is a good one China's a
good one Philippines Cambodia honestly I
know I'm I sound like a guy selling uh
you know brushes but I'm the Australian
Outback's fantastic yeah you've got
basically crazy no you can't really I
would I would probably say you you
alluded to it at the start of us Jane
I don't think you should start with
season one no because it's not the show
that you guys ever envisaged you could
go back after watching a few seasons and
go ah here's the Genesis yeah yeah but
it really starts to catch fire I think
round about season three or four and
then it's just it's it's getting better
and better I I it's hard for me to
answer it because I'm aware of
I'm aware that I'm talking about the
show I work on yeah yeah I think our
storytelling is as good as it's ever
been yeah it's brilliant this is what a
Dom says he says when you meet him he
says he's he's he loves this show he
really loves it in a way that I drink my
own Kool-Aid it's brilliant which is a
great thing you know to be involved in a
show that you love so much yeah you're
so passionate about it you're so
positive about it there's you've always
been such a positive person but there's
there's nothing jaded about having done
43 seasons of the same show you still
love that well I'll tell you what it
really feels good this is the truth
when performers other storytellers like
you
I have a group of writer friends who've
written gigantic stuff Big Time movies
we've all seen
and when they write and say last night's
episode or that scene sequence where
this this and this happens it's so
gratifying because that's what that's
what we feel we're doing is we're
telling a story it's built inside a game
and it's players living on an island
these are all the facts and the the
players the characters whatever you want
to call them but what we're seeing is
this epic individual adventure of people
overcoming odds to see what they're
capable of achieving and sometimes it is
mind-blowing and sometimes it's tiny
like we have an episode coming up this
season with somebody I won't say man or
woman or anyone but somebody
who has a very small moment involving a
puzzle that they solve
and in interview they say
despite having all these degrees and all
this education
they say you know
I never I was always kind of told that I
wasn't good at this stuff
I am I am I just did that and I saw that
interview and went wow you've lived all
these years and that tiny little silly
puzzle in the middle of Fiji actually
was meaningful to you yeah yeah maybe
that's why you came out here maybe you
will never again doubt that you are good
at that stuff yeah yeah yeah I love that
too I'm always surprised at the end of
the challenge is I don't think I've seen
it yet the a losing team excuse me a
losing team has not said to you hey Jeff
can we just finish it yeah it's never
happened yeah I thought the week before
last when Cody's team lost the the
puzzle challenge and they were close I I
genuinely thought they were going to say
could you give us 10 minutes and let's
just finish just for our own sense of
satisfaction but I guess they're all so
beat at that point right I think that's
a big part of it and demoralized and
immediately thinking about tribal right
right I mean you immediately see people
go yeah we lost who's it gonna be yeah
that's me and I think if it was really a
big time suck you know we also have the
confines of sun like we have to get you
back to Camp so that we can let you
decide who you're going to vote out
tonight so we we also have a ticking
clock we got to get you in the boat get
you back to Camp give you time to
strategize and do what you want because
once the sun goes down we're going to
tribal yeah yeah
if you you've probably been asked this
question a million times before if you
were able to Frankenstein the perfect
Survivor contestant to win the game out
of out of people that have come and gone
what would you that's a good question
together
it's really that's a great question
especially lately because we've worked
really hard to put on likable rootable
people you know I love everybody that's
if if we don't have unanimous consent by
our producing team you're not going to
get on so you know if you're on we want
you here so how many producers have to
say yes quite a few I'd have to count
but I mean it's a it's a handful and
and on the flip side if one person only
one person really wanted somebody and
nobody else did I don't think they I
don't think you get to play that chip we
used to talk about you can you can have
one player who do you want but it's now
it's gotten to where if we're not all
seeing it then let's just wait and bring
them back next year and talk to you know
talk to us so I think what I'm getting
at is the Hall of Fame of Survivor is
full of great players who will never win
because it's impossible to win yeah it's
impossible so I think the skills are you
know you have you obviously have to be a
good read you have to have emotional
intelligence if you don't understand
when something sideways you're in
trouble but you also have to be able to
be duplicitous with the right people and
be loyal to the right people sometimes
the right move is is telling the truth
because Billy is going to be loyal and
we're both going to go to the end and
one of us will win but we're gonna get
there you and me might play and you
might might be an interview going I
can't believe props is going to believe
me all the times we've talked about this
but I'm taking him out tonight so
I don't know but I I try to say uh even
though I know it's easy to say and hard
to do to play the first time as though
you're playing the second time
because oh that's a great Point what
what people that are in the Survivor
Hall of Fame have never said is Woulda
Coulda Shoulda right they might say ah I
played the idol I didn't need to that
cost me but they don't say I was afraid
to play no no and but it's easy to say
because you only get to play once
probably and you want you want every
minute
but if you want to win
you have to play to win because I'm
watching too and if you get to the end
and I think you weren't playing to win
I'll never give you my vote because I
played to win and I'm out so I'm going
to give it to the other dude or the
other woman who played hard and beat me
yeah yeah but that's easy to say it's
like are you gonna go for a home run
knowing you may strike out or you're
just gonna try to get your bat on the
ball two different outcomes yeah yeah I
mean it feels like the people with the
biggest swings the most bombastic kind
of plays they obviously stick their neck
out but they usually go pretty far in
the game also the contestants that have
won it twice is extraordinary right
Russian rubs one twice no no no only
twice Sandra and Tony Sandra and Tony oh
you'd like Tony yeah Tony's a really
interested in New York firemen so so the
thing that Tony did spying at the well
right that's within the rules of the
game
so too much
so where they go to pick up the fresh
water every day Tony like erected a
little hide and would like the Spy Shack
the Spy Shack nice to listen in to what
people were saying and it paid off for
him a couple of years he works so hard
out there that's he's an interesting so
he built a little thing that he could
hide them and imagine you gotta do that
while other people well other rounds you
got to be really clever because if you
leave they think you're doing spooning
you're looking for another he was always
leaving now
uh what's his name the you know the kind
of the little the little hobby guy that
that was with poverty that no one really
oh Russell him and Russell were always
right leaving and it's a different game
now Russell would have to adapt his game
yeah even though if he listens to this
he'll say no I wouldn't but greatest of
all time but he would have to adapt but
he might be able to right you can't play
that game today right but yeah you play
a different game genuinely looks like an
evil Hobbit Billy if you can picture an
evil Hobbit I can
um I wanted to ask you Jeff because I
very I don't think I've seen you bristle
too many times the only time I ever see
you bristle on the show
it's in the finale where we're finding
out who's winning
and someone out of the contestants that
have been brought back for the finale
will mention the editing and you'll go
here we go yeah
and I want we all know in creating a
show there has to be choices to be made
but I wanted you to respond because you
never respond you're just gonna go okay
okay we're moving on to that thing
but I'd like to hear you respond to the
fact that of course this is a
entertainment show you have to make
editorial decisions yeah and it's not
you're not telling a story that didn't
happen these are stories that happened
so could you just speak about that for a
sec in the editing Bays they're probably
not posted anymore but as annoying as
this will sound
kind of early on when I sort of took on
the show running I wrote this you know
this man of this Jerry Maguire moment
which is basically here's what our
moments have to be and it was they have
to be honest they can be funny they can
be adversarial they can be visceral but
they have to have happened which means
when you're editing if we do an
interview with you on day one and you
talk about the marooning and we do an
interview with you on day through on day
three and you talk about the marooning
we might marry those two interviews
they're both about the same thing the
marooning that's exactly what happened
so that kind of structuring of a scene
is completely realistic and and normal
what wouldn't be okay would be to take
what you said on day one and pull out a
few words so that you actually are
saying something different so we would
never do that so that's our fundamental
thing then you get into
players feel like oh you didn't show my
the time I told all those jokes
and they're right there's
so much great material but we have a
show to tell and our thing is this is a
murder mystery if you structure it like
a murder mystery who will be killed
tonight that's what we're looking at so
your funny stories they just didn't fit
sometimes they do and you get in or most
commonly as hard as it is to hear for
former players you're not exactly who
you think you are right when you look in
the mirror you are sometimes more
annoying maybe it's because you're not
eating you're not quite as funny and all
those interviews about you
I mean they're telling you the same
thing so I always I always feel bad
because I get it I mean look at me I've
been doing this 22 years I could point
to a hundred things that I wish weren't
on the show that people mock me about
yeah I'm I'm evolving too but the
biggest thing I hear
is the winners at it that's the one that
gets me oh he's getting the winners at
it she's getting the winners at it I'm
here to tell you there is no such thing
as winners at it there's nobody in our
team that would say well props we do
have a Winner's head right right we look
at the show we know now we're we're
writing it
just in a different way when in your in
you know Lord of the Rings somebody
wrote all these scenes and all these
words and then they hire you to come in
and bring this thing to life and bring
whatever you are and make it and that's
now what it is and then somebody edits
it and they twist it somebody puts music
to it the only difference is we don't
write anything we structure a game and
the specifics of what's going to happen
the players write it right and then we
go back and say now treat it like a
mystery pull out that clue because
that'll give it away leave that clue in
because that's fun to nibble on and now
at the end you're like who's it gonna be
and sometimes you're right and sometimes
you're wrong right I mean it's always
the sour person in the finale that says
well you know you edited and you're like
well that's because you didn't win it's
never the winner that goes well you
should exactly they were perfect it's a
little bit of sour grapes for those guys
um I think my all-time favorite episodes
in Survivor
uh the merging of the tribes and the
feast because very shrewdly you will
often have alcohol at that Feast little
wine a little wine nothing too crazy but
they've not drank for a couple of weeks
they haven't eaten much yeah not eaten
much either they all get a little loose
they'll get a little light-headed and
just as you said there they're not quite
as funny as they think they are they're
not quite as Dynamic you'll get someone
that's had three or four glasses or two
or three glasses and they let rip and
then they'll probably get voted off that
day it often happens yeah and and you're
reminding me that
a lot of times players will say they
didn't show that I was in charge of that
vote they made it seem like Billy was
The Mastermind and that that is
subjective right you know we have all
the information we have what they don't
have we have every single person telling
us so we're gonna go with what we're
told but it's possible that you really
believe you were the one that influenced
it and what you did was gave Billy the
agency to believe it was his so that
stuff gets a little sticky because
there's never a an objective answer to
who was in control yeah because
everybody is the hero yeah
yeah well should we eat the world well I
think so I'm starting to feel like one
of the survivors I'm starving
Billy and Dom eat the world every every
week on the podcast we ask people to
bring in something that has an
interesting story and you brought in
something that I love as well yeah these
are boring but I know you I think you
like this that's my favorite the black
one do you have a choice uh I'll go with
that one okay peanut butter now you said
you live on these well okay what's the
other one blueberry
yes
well what was the brown thing that you
didn't like build peanut butter I like
peanut butter but I don't like peanut
butter flavored things I like eating
peanut butter he's a strange man Jeff
well these are just these aren't peanut
butter see that's what these bars are so
let's talk about the Earth bar this is
what's in your peanut butter chocolate
three egg whites 14 peanuts two dates
and no BS they keep it simple 14 peanuts
no 14 dates isn't it no 14 two dates 14
peanuts 14 pain and chocolate wow so
I'll tell you what's the main time three
egg whites I need that because I'm
Balkan just now okay I'll tell you about
that I've started I've started about six
months ago I thought I want to get I
want to see how strong I can get really
well honestly wow and I started bulking
and I love it I love eating it's really
it's really fun have you seen Game of
Thrones Jeff yes do you remember the
mountain in Game of Thrones yes I'm
trying to reach Mountain stairs and I
was like I fully support this movement I
love it you're doing well I did I tell
you what I love writing down what I've
lifted and then you know adding 10
pounds and then adding 10 pounds and
then looking back and saying I am a
Monster yeah
just for the audience that may not be
watching this but just listening you
don't appear to be quite as big as the
monster but I'm getting there for 66
months ago it's a journey well you
you're obviously in great shape Jeff in
that time that you're away making
Survivor is there a gym is there access
to a gym for you obviously I started
bringing a gym or building a gym
probably early on with like just a
little piece of gear and that's really
all I have is a few pieces of gear but
I need it because anybody that works out
and feels this way will understand it I
get energy
from doing a workout oh absolutely yeah
I'm not tired afterwards but I can get
really the lethargic if I'm not doing it
you're the same yeah so I really do I
only care about Survivor when I'm on
location we're isolated from the world I
can call my wife and kids and you know
with the time difference we talk for a
little bit mostly all I care about
what's happening on the beach what's
happening and then I just want to try to
be my best version of myself and so
having these bars
I will eat easily four bars a day no
problem and I could eat more than that
so when you you've been packing a bag to
go away for Survivor right for decades
now
so the these you ship right they're not
part of you guys so what are the
essentials what are the essentials that
people wouldn't expect when you're going
to Survivor for you where you're like
well it's changed because in the
beginning State early days we lived in
the weirdest place we lived in tents
then we would live in these little tiny
modular sort of homes where you didn't
have showers so you brought all kinds of
stuff but now we've kind of got it
refined even though we're not on a an
amazing Resort this place in Fiji Mana
gives us everything we need so we have
our own rooms we have our own bathrooms
we have our own showers I don't really
take much right I mean I've had the same
t-shirts on location
at least I have a shirt from Ethan Zahn
who was in Survivor Africa his
Grassroots Soccer Organization oh yeah
that he gave me in probably season five
that I've had on location every single
season that I wear when I so if you saw
me on location I look like I'm an
unhoused person who's been away for a
while
so I really don't so mostly you would
see
These Bars and coffee like little pods
Billy's obsessed with coffee okay I I
didn't find coffee till like six years
ago I started drinking it during covet
and I've now quit but you started
drinking it six years ago and you're
still going I quit I reached I reached
the limit where so it's true of course
you did during covet I said to Billy uh
these days are so long like I'm waking
up at five in the morning because I'm
not doing anything and I'm not feeling
tired to go to bed until 10 o'clock at
night and Billy said in in his morning
he said I have a little practice that
goes on for an hour I you know work out
what coffee beans I'm gonna grind and
then I grind them and I warm up the milk
and get everything going and he said it
takes you know 40 minutes to an hour so
it's a nice little process you should
try it he sent me a link to this Italian
little cafeteria thing I did it first
week I was I I loved it the little Buzzy
feeling wasn't over the moon about the
taste but I was okay with it with the
Buzzy feeling of I'm gonna spring clean
my house I don't get the Buzzy feeling
anymore so so I sat down and I was like
if you don't get the Buzzy feeling you
don't really like the taste all you're
doing is spiking your adrenal glands and
it's not doing anything for you I hate
hearing this I know I've not drank
coffee for probably three years I love
it yeah I've always drunk it I always
will drink it I drink it all day I like
being stubborn now I'll drink it all
night actually nobody's telling you you
can't there's no words we'll go for
dinner together and he'll order a latte
when we get in the check I'm like what
are you doing he's like no it doesn't
keep me away yeah it doesn't keep me
awake either no but I like that I'm
going to sleep right after espresso it
doesn't bother me I love it yeah I love
the taste of it I love just having it in
my hand do you know what else yeah okay
you know what else I learned to love
during covet potato chips oh oh yeah
that was a new one for me and now I I
will send from Amazon you know the
little packs that have like six potato
chips in them yeah yeah oh my cupboard
is full of those and I find when I come
home in the afternoon I'm craving that
salt yeah
what's your favorite flavor Hawaiian
potato chips oh we were going to do it I
love that so that's a simple salt
nothing else I'm pretty sure okay how
does an RX bar I'm asking here as some
dude doesn't know that's got egg whites
almonds cashews and dates become that
texture I must whip it did they whip it
do you know how they make it absolutely
not no it doesn't tell us in my notes I
can tell you a few things about them if
you want to know sure yeah but Billy
just to clarify Jeff does not make the
RX bars I know but I just thought I'd
give you some facts about it because I
like them and all now that's lovely that
did you know that the founders Peter
Rahal and Jared Smith started directs
bars in the kitchen and nope that sounds
like a good place
okay no Consultants no office no best
friends eager and broke they wanted
everything about the beginnings up front
and in the open just like the
ingredients of the protein bars
good I like that I've tried to make
protein bars with a friend who's a chef
and getting them to stay together like
this that's the hard part without using
a sugar or you know that must be the
days maybe the date yeah I mean
particularly the egg white because
that's quite sticky I love the texture
of it and if you like the texture of a
food I think you're halfway there yeah
such as a Haribo yeah it's got that sort
of I only eat the black ones I've tried
the blueberry ones they're okay I've
tried the peanut butter ones they're
okay I keep the black ones in my fridge
it's uh dark chocolate sea salt almonds
really good it's really good yeah that's
just delicious yeah it's and it's good
for you there's a few of these type of
bars out there on the market which I
will not mention any names where after
the gym I used to eat them and then when
I looked at the ingredients I was like
this is all sugar yeah it's just sugar
yeah makes you feel crappy these never
make me feel crazy same a great snack
the same I'm not pitching these eyes
I never feel bad after reading them but
they will if you're hungry they will
definitely stop that craving for a
second until you can you know get 12
grams of protein yeah that's pretty good
which for somebody who's broken like
myself right yeah yeah
no uh like what we do Jeff
um on the Friendship onion as we score
it out of ten oh okay and a few
different things the first one being
flavor and you can have good taste yeah
or taste okay flavor we add on this well
for me and you can use decimal points
I'm gonna get that
a 9.5 really wow you found something new
WoW nothing as a bar to keep you going
and good for you that I don't think you
could get much better and you're bulking
and I'm bulking's pretty good I think
that's I'm gonna buy them for no reason
to buy easy to get yeah they're
everywhere I love these things too
they're always on my shopping list uh
they're always in my fridge especially
the dark chocolate one I can't fault
this for Taste and or flavor it's
getting that 10 out of 10. what's going
on bills it's just my watch is talking
to me I think it's adding RX bars to my
shopping oh nice well you'll you'll
thank that later Jeff out of ten
yeah I'm right there I like them
blueberry is actually my favorite so I
get blueberry at 10. 10 out of ten yeah
sorry I took that one from that's all
right I brought it for you it's
delicious
if I was stuck in a desert island I
would well the other thing about an RX
bar is if you like that really sweet
protein bar this isn't it it's not but
it's got enough it satisfies it but I
know what you mean some of them are so
good yeah when you eat them sugar yeah
and then you're over and you're like
okay chocolate which is not good for you
um
we'll still talk about the RX bars but
while we do that the next category is
Aesthetics the way that it looks which
will also include the like labeling of
the I like the labeling very clean uh
yeah I will say it's a shame that it's
made of plastic you would think these
guys would be like you know what we're
cool and groovy we're going to make the
packaging out of something that um that
you can buy a degrade a little easier or
it's edible or it's edible you know this
little packaging nowadays that like
turns into seeds plant seeds have you
seen that uh-huh yeah so there'll be
something made out of a type of paper
and then it says just just put this in
the ground yeah and encased in the paper
uh flowers wow seeds amazing
um but it's a good design it's a 7.6 for
me for design I like I like the look of
the bar
and I'm going to take into the texture
even though it's not Aesthetics because
I love the texture I think the packaging
is fantastic telling you what's in it
big on the front
I'm gonna give that
a 9.5 oh you're loving it I love it I'm
right there with you I appreciate this
because I feel the message that that
they're sending is what they write on
there which is no BS I probably would
have I probably would have experimented
with it just a hint more of life like a
little bit more pop but if I were going
with the no BS I might have ended up
right back here which is nope simple
color scheme this is brown and orange
it's the offset and uh that's it minimum
light lettering yep here's a little
piece of trivia for you because I've
been eating RX bars for years and this
happens every time every time I eat an
RX bar I will eventually turn it into
the map of Spain always every single
time so if you hold the corner and you
keep eating there's Spain that's funny
you guys are done yeah thanks snacks
that's where my mum and dad live just
down the bottom ah um here's another
little fact in 2017 those two guys that
I mentioned to you uh Peter Rahal and
Jared Smith sold it to Kellogg's for 600
million dollars
they were in their kitchen with three
egg whites and a couple of nuts next
thing they know they've got 300 million
dollars each hey Billy that's 300
million dollars eight well we need to
think of something yeah yeah well how's
you going on the underwater helicopter
invention well that's going okay and the
time machine's coming on and all good
um
wait have we done the last thing no
Billy's favorite category that you came
up with Billy
how useful is it as a food source
can you do other things with it can it
be crumbled up and yeah okay can you use
it for soup I'm not saying this right
but you know right can you travel with
it can you put it in your pocket how
useful is it in Dom
even if you do nothing else with this
it's incredibly useful I would think
it's great to put in your pocket and go
off on a hike and then you're like oh
I'm hungry I've got it right here you
can give it like to if you know I would
think your kids are that without feeling
bad about it I'm not giving them extra
sugars it's a hard thing is it's
actually very useful as well Jeff Probst
uses it to uh stay alive while we can
Survivor how about that when he's stuck
in Fiji I'm going to use it now to help
me bulk do it Monster it's leg day today
Jeff oh that's a damn day it's not my
favorite day but hey it's got to be done
it does my favorite it's my favorite
like day because I hate it so much
that's the way that I reverse engineered
it it was always my least favorite uh
day in the gym I was like I'm just gonna
flip the script so when it's like there
I'm like woohoo it's leg day and I used
to really loathe it that's good to be
yourself I'm not sick leg day sometimes
big muscles it's big muscle well big on
you because you're bulking um usefulness
um for me it's an eight it's useful I'm
going to say it's a nine for me wow yeah
it's a useful food source I think yeah
I'm with you I'll go uh I'll go nine
here as well leaving a little room for
some something but and I feel good about
these guys making 600 miles
you know they made something honest and
good yeah I love it that's a great thing
you bring Jeff the Arts Bar wins yeah
that's a big one Jeff whenever we have
people on the show
because this is this is a show about
positivity as well and seeing if we can
inspire people we we try and find out
the route that our guests went to get to
the lofty position that they found they
are at now if there's someone out there
that thinks I would love to be a host of
a TV show I would love to follow in the
Jeff Probst path what what advice would
you give someone that wants to go down
there
uh that's very specific today
um
I never really looked at it as hosting
as much as I wanted to be a Storyteller
and I always wanted to be behind the
camera and I made a couple of little
movies
but then I realized when I was just
starting I got hired to host some
corporate videos you know where you
would like do stuff for Eddie Bauer or
some company
and then I realized oh the power of the
performer is you're locking that
performance you two locked you know you
locked in these things that are in our
you know Zeitgeist now and so being on
both sides was really appealing I never
dreamed it would manifest in this way
where I get to be the host of Survivor
and also be behind the scenes helping to
create it but
getting the job turned on what I thought
was the worst job I had ever had which
was
I did a bunch of work in Seattle and
then I got a job at FX
which was this uh live television
network before it became FX scripted it
was just this live thing in New York it
was really fun and
and Peter feyman ran it and what he said
was it was you're just live television
all day all day and there was a bunch of
hosts there and he said just try
something
and if it works do it again and if it
doesn't work try something else so that
was the first thing I was taught was
just be Fearless just try it
then I'd come to LA and I get a job at
Access Hollywood and I still know lots
of people at access and I like them
wasn't for me I did not like the red
rope that touched my authority issues
and I also didn't really like having to
ask celebrities questions they didn't
want to be asked it was so it just
didn't work for me and but one of the
interviews I did was with Sandra Bullock
and you know when you two do interviews
you're trying to give the the person
interviewing you something unique so
that they can do something with it not
the same answer even though it's the
same question she did that with me she
was just really nice to me she doesn't
know me she doesn't know me to this day
but we kind of flirted in a playful way
about her blouse being buttoned
unbuttoned low
and she went with it and I put that on
my demo tape it was it's ridiculous but
what I'm getting to is when I finally
got hired by Mark I said what was it
why'd you pick me and he said two things
you had done thousands of hours of live
television at FX and I knew the show was
going to be live in a jungle taped but
live and you had this interview with
Sandra Bullock and I thought well if
she's willing to be that friendly with
you then you know maybe other people
I'll talk to you little did he know she
was just you know she was just a good
human doing me a solid but I always
remember and say to people the job I
hated
for a year was the job that led me to
the job I loved so you just never
noticed say yes just say yes you you
know we know in our business we meet
people like I don't know if I'm going to
do it really you're certain your phone's
gonna ring tomorrow dude you should say
yes immediately and be so lucky to be
stuck on that show and as you see it may
yeah it may be something that you're
like I shouldn't but someone sees that
and then that leads to the thing that
you're like this is what I want to do
but if you hadn't done that one who
knows you wouldn't have maybe got that
yeah when right wind Survivor was
launching I had gotten a million dollars
to make a movie with with Ryan Reynolds
and James Earl Jones and
um Robert Forster who's passed away
recently but
um
when the movie is over it's a really
fast shooting candidate it was a tiny
little movie I couldn't believe I had
these actors saying yes and Ryan
Reynolds was not Ryan Reynolds but he
was incredibly talented even then
when it was over survivors were cutting
it and survivors hitting and it's
becoming popular it's the first season
Forester calls me and says let's take a
walk so we go hike Runyon Canyon in LA
and he goes I'm going to tell you a
story
I had a good career going it's in some
movies and then I did a movie that
bombed and I didn't get work again for
25 years until Quentin Tarantino came
into a little cafe and dropped Jackie
Brown in front of me you're going to be
tempted to leave Survivor this Show's
gonna run ride this wave until you hit
the sand and I didn't even really know
what he meant I knew what he was saying
but like I'd never been on a popular
show I didn't know what he was talking
about and as the years went by that
wisdom
became more and more clear that he was
telling me I've been where Europe could
head don't be the dummy that says you're
going to do something else and I've had
those moments as I'm sure you can
imagine we're like God I am kind of
tired of doing the same show but now I
look back and go oh thank God yeah was
in my head yeah yeah yeah amazing well
that's brilliant Jeff as always
extremely inspiring it's great to chat
to you love chatting with YouTube yeah
well you've certainly got a new fan in
me the show and you as a person yeah
really lovely yeah lovely to chat with
you Survivor day today so we get to
drive home and watch another episode
it's fun we're definitely having a um
finale I would say a pizza night you're
not invasive really well could I invite
your wife to my house
my wife is loving it as well she's new
to it as well well tell her hey she's
loving it it's such a fun it's great
show and it's got a great feel about it
even though it is
a a game that people are backstabbing is
that for some reason there's a there's
an optimistic feel about it yeah I don't
know why there's a fantastic escapism to
survive yeah the color scheme the
animals the ocean
if I've ever kind of had a little bit of
a home drum day going into that world
where you're like wow look at this place
out there look at this amazing Planet
you'll live on it's very positive ah I
love hearing all that Jeff it's been
fantastic to have you thanks boys thanks
man
um all right you guys we'll see you next
week uh great review And subscribe to
the podcast you can get our merch at the
friendship onionpodcast.com and you can
check us out on YouTube French bunion
yeah and leave leave a message at
speakpay.com forward slash the
Friendship onion we're off to watch
Survivor we'll see you next week Turtles
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your place the
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]